right now is the golden age of dinosaurs
in terms of the scientific understanding
of them essentially have a new species
of dinosaur every week we also have this
this entirely new understanding of what
the animals actually looked like when
they were alive we tried to show
behaviors of dinosaurs that are
unexpected and also unexpected dinosaurs
wired spoke with tim walker and dr
derenesh to explore how filmmakers and
scientists work together to bring
prehistoric species to life on screen
in apple's new doc series prehistoric
planet filmmakers brought to life
dinosaurs in some ways we've never seen
and others for the very first time
new research and discoveries about
dinosaurs in the last decade meant that
filmmakers needed to reconcile popular
depictions to the new research available
take the t-rex we have what are called
trace fossils and these are scrape marks
which have been left by theropod
dinosaurs left in in sediment on the
bottom of waterways and then you look at
the bones of a t-rex they are air-filled
if you reconstruct in computer modelling
the t-rex body all indicating that t-rex
would have been a swimmer tyrannosaurus
and other predatory dinosaurs they
almost certainly didn't have the kind of
crocodile-like faces scientific evidence
currently indicates that these animals
actually had quite a lot of soft tissue
on the face they would have structures
that we call lips but they're not lips
like what we have they're more like the
lips of lizards and snakes lots of
depictions of dinosaurs they're like
super bodybuilders when we see them but
in reality when you look across the
animal kingdom and you see
animals that have a healthy lifestyle
they are often very different to how you
depict dinosaurs so our t-rex is quite
chunky
in addition to reimagining fan favorites
like the t-rex the team depicted 12
rarely seen species what could be cooler
dinosaurs and snob is a wonderful
dinosaur called nanukosaurus which is a
type of tyrannosaur it would have been
perfectly adapted to its environment the
nanook saw is rather cunning it looks
amazing as well an oliver titan is a
type of hadrosaur the name means giant
swan neck it's a beautiful creature we
show it moving into a nesting area where
it ultimately uses geothermal energy to
incubate the eggs so we've known since
the 1980s that there were dinosaurs of
all kinds large and small living in the
far north and the far south but a 2021
discovery of baby dinosaur bones in
alaska pushed researchers to consider
that dinosaurs lived year-round in the
cold so these were animals that must
have coped with seasonal polar darkness
and freezing cold temperatures and thick
snow it's entirely new it's entirely
radical to most of the people that are
going to see the episode but it's
absolutely scientifically legit so we
kicked the episode off with giant
titanosaur sauropods called
dreadnaughtus we then see incredibly
adorned pterosaurs called
barbaroductless and we close the episode
with a wonderful story about
sacronosaurus traveling across sand
dunes dreadnaughtus is a
south american titanosaur it's got a
huge long neck really long tail massive
the giant plant-eating dinosaurs were
probably the most dangerous of the
dinosaurs think about the living world
there's no such thing as a gentle giant
they're the animals you stay away from
barbara daxlas is a fabulous animal that
features in the desert episode it's a
pterosaur that's got a huge huge head
crest you know if we look in the animal
kingdom
anytime that an animal has something
which doesn't really have a a mechanical
function usually always associated with
some kind of display purpose usually for
attracting a mate or or warding off
rivals we show velociraptor looking very
different to what people have got used
to seeing over the last few years
velociraptor was around about the size
of a big turkey and covered in feathers
still had a big claw so it'd be a pretty
vicious turkey
throughout prehistoric planet we don't
just feature dinosaurs so dinosaurs were
quite a specific group of animals that
lived on land the things in the air we
call flying reptiles and the things in
the water we call marine reptiles these
specialized marine reptiles none of them
laid eggs they give birth to live babies
in the water this kind of believes it's
all turangasaurus and we've been able to
show that give births in our coasts
episode by a discovery it's actually a
fossil that's on display in los angeles
county museum where there's a pregnant
plesiosaur so we know for sure that
plesiosaurs like tarangisaurus gave
birth to these giant babies now if you
give birth to a giant baby and again
this is something seen across the animal
world they generally undergo parental
care so we've got very good reason for
thinking that plesiosaurs like
terangiosaurus lived in complex family
groups looked after their babies
now in the last several decades there's
actually been a scientific revolution
kaikai fulu is is a mosasaur people used
to show mosasaurs as kind of like
crocodile-like animals that is
completely wrong beautiful fossils all
discovered since about the year 2000
have shown that they were more like kind
of whale lizards they were these big
chubby streamlined animals and they had
a vertical tail fit kind of like a shark
one of the frogs that lived in the lake
cretaceous specifically in madagascar
was probably the most remarkable frog
ever it's called beelzy buffo this
predatory broad-bodied frog it looks
kind of similar to the modern pac-man
frogs and the pixie frogs scientists
have worked out based on the bite
strength of living frogs that bielsa
bufo would have bitten at a strength of
around about 2
000 newtons it's about the same as the
bike force of like a lion or a tiger so
a a frog that can grab like an animal
like a small dinosaur subdue it with
this really powerful bite force and then
eat it
[Music]
magikasaurus you know when we see it
it's got babies with it we've got a
giant toad and we've got some baby
dinosaurs and kind of guess what happens
i think a lot of people think that
dinosaurs lived in swamps or in deserts
but we know that the planet was covered
in a lot of forest and the dinosaurs
were found in those forests a cool one
we feature is qinzo saurus which is a
type of tyrannosaur it's got a
colloquial name which is pinocchio rex
because it's got a really elongated
snout and we show it in association with
a beautiful dinosaur called karitharapta
the conventional view of dinosaurs
that's still really familiar to us
through most mainstream media is that
dinosaurs were boring and brown and
pretty ugly animals and all they did was
roar each other and attack each other
dinosaurs non-bird dinosaurs were showy
flamboyant often attractive animals they
would have been sending signals to each
other you know head shakes and arm
waving and tail wiggling all this kind
of stuff all the time so if you were
lucky enough to travel back in time to
see these animals in life you would be
just blown away by how showy and amazing
they were in appearance